hallo mein name ist luca das ist max wie
ihr seht ihr schon hier oben ein werde
meine damen und herren das ganze ist ein
werbevideo und zwar in kooperation mit
google play und zwar kam google
fernsehens und meinte hey habt ihr
braucht euch ein spiel aus dem google
places runterzuladen das zusammenwachsen
ich ja erst mal kurz darstellen wie es
war
ich bin nur player sogar bei der place
du kannst meine dabei zu sein ja
diejenigen unter euch die lesen können
keiner kannte wir haben uns die hatten
eher 2017 heruntergeladen hier sieht es
gerade schon eingeblendet das ist das
logo baugerät logo und alkohol wer von
uns heute reicher wird
ich bin krank ich glaube schon dann
legen wir los
sehr geehrter herr kommen ich heiße sie
herzlich willkommen zu millionären 2017
hallo und herzlich willkommen hier heute
das ja ja ja sind sie in den b wir
beginnen mit der ersten frage das ist
jetzt die erste frage 50 euro frage 50
euro ist die 50 euro frage warum sucht
der sondengänger gezielt nach
gegenständen im boden itf laubsauger bvc
metalldetektor oder de gass ventil womit
sucht der sondengänger kann es natürlich
auch schon ein 50 50 joint venture oder
100 100 j doch nicht kommt auch nicht
chef laubsauger b-feld spaten 10
metalldetektor oder das ventil ich würde
sagen c metalldetektor so ist einloggen
sie seien
das ist richtig herzlichen glückwunsch
50 euro gehen an sie und ihre familie
das waren 500 euro klappt schon mal
drauf ach leistung bei ihnen starten
jetzt auch mit der ersten frage herr
kran wer in einer schlimmen lage ist
sitzt in der tinte b auf der binde auf
einem kinder oder die in der pinte
bestimmt das stimmt da steht ihr so
mache nur in der tinte sind das ist
nämlich dass hier in der tinte und alles
klar okay sind bei 50 eur vj wird im
bayrischen das oktoberfest genannt
stunden b walten
sie wiesen den hügeln ich wiederhole die
frage hätte ich will mir jetzt echt
nicht so sicher ich tendiere gerade
zwischen e und f warme ware und schade
weil fc schalke 04 wir waren ja selber
auch schon da auf den hügeln auf den
hügeln waren wir ja soll ich das
einloggen oder hügeln ja
nochmal ich lege mich mal ganz weit aus
dem fenster und sage c wiesen alles
reingelegt wir haben das ist korrekt und
euro alter fit waren sogar noch wirklich
100 euro auf welchem schiff gab es eine
meuterei die in die geschichte einging
duplo bsc hanuta oder die bounty wenn du
mir wieder nicht glaubst hier sind die
direkt dem 50 50 50 50 joker ist
eingeloggt meine damen und herren tricks
oder bauen
hätte ich aber auch von anfang an hätte
ich hätte ja auch von anfang an gesagt
ist auch richtig ist richtig dass
korrekt 200 euro frage war wer aus der
sesamstraße bringt kindern im
vorschulalter das zählen bei alter ich
habe schon drei oder vier mal auf einem
kanal in sesamstraße spiel gespielt
keine ahnung
graf zahl der könig 1c graf zifferblatt
oder de lord ziffer also ich tendiere
wirklich zwischen a und c ich glaube der
heißt irgendwas mit graf gesagt dass
wenn ich ein 50 50 joker machen würde
dann wäre halt wahrscheinlich a und c
weil ich glaube definitiv zu wissen dass
ich nicht weiß was dann leichter freunde
freunde übrigens bock auf mehr mobile
gaming habt ihr jetzt hier oben irgendwo
abstimmung eingeblendet da könnt ihr
einfach abstimmen und dann sehe ich auch
ihr solche formate öfter sehen wollt
dann konnte ich muss jetzt wirklich
bitten mir die antwort zu geben ich wohl
ein letztes mal die frage und die
antwort möglichkeiten ich nehme den
telefonjoker
ich weiß nicht was nun passiert aber
auch wichtig mal ein paar sekunden
später aber die richtige antwort
doch die richtige antwort ist graf zahl
alter das wollte ich erst neben solch
einlagen
ja und das ist richtig ich gratuliere
200 euro
das war kaka ich mag einfach mal drauf
geschlagen bekennen sich einfach die
dritte frage max gramberger her kann der
kran ja richtig castor behälter sind
spezialbehälter zur lagerung und zum
transport von a säurehaltiger fässer b
salzhaltiger würste zenit haltiger
streiche oder die radioaktive
materialien die radioaktive materialien
hätte ich auch gesagt korrekt max dann
gibt es eine kunst die haben 200 euro
wie nennt man auch einen kalt
hergestellten schokoladen kekse kuchen
kalte maus b
kalter hund c kalte ente oder der kalte
krieg ich weiß dass meine oma hat das
immer gemacht
ich glaube ich weiß auch ich glaube
kalter hund die sache jetzt das bringt
auch gar nicht wenn du mit tipps gibt's
bei mir sogar mit einer bestrafung das
ganze heute machen werde heute aus den
ganzen runden weniger geld mit einem
muss ich nämlich glitzer nägel machen
mein gott also was meinst du einloggen
ich würde mich gern mal wieder mein
youtube account einloggen
ich sage kalter hund katar unglaublich
ein werde ich ein und das ist richtig
okay dreimal hat die scheiße drauf die
sportfreunde vor welches tier liefert
das sogenannte eisbein ist es das huhn b
das rind c
die altbekannte ziele oder die das
schlimme schwein was man übrigens pixel
262 das schwein ja ich denke auf schwein
und ist richtig auch sehr gut als
schwein
weil das wird schon schwierig die soll
die frage beantworten was zur hölle was
nimmt man soll den zuwendet ist
beantwortet dass man sich dann kannst du
nicht weiter ist verwundert euro
zurückfallen
okay das bild habe wie viele zentimeter
durchmesser spricht man beim
niederschlag von hagel 5 cm b 0,5 cm 5
cm sc 0 1 cm oder de 1 cm also die 15
also die drei anderen kleineren werte
waren 0,1 0,5 und 1 zentimeter alter ok
0,1 cm auch ein millimeter genannt in
kennerkreisen er weiß aber nicht jeder
publikumsjoker bringt mir nichts weil da
wird wahrscheinlich irgend was rauskommt
von den drei kleineren zahlen was ich
schon weiß 50 50 bringt mir auch nichts
da ich den 50 50 irgendwas bleiben übrig
0,5 zentimeter und 1 zentimeter 0,5 cm
würges 1
und das ist richtig 500 euro jetzt ist
die 300 euro frage herr kran welches
tier überredete eva eine frucht vom baum
der ja ja das zu essen ich wollte sagen
dass das doch ohne die dinge hinkriegen
so ja kommen 500 euro haben sie uns
sicher gratuliere erstmal wir kommen
direkt zur nächsten frage in welcher
sportart werden mit einem punkt tore
erzielt a scot w
eishockey fußball oder die basketball
definitiv fußball fußball und basketball
ist es nicht dass er das erste was war
schon das zweite war okay okay
richtig ich gratuliere 1000 euro sind
ganz mehr sicher ist so viel kann ich
nicht sagen
max ist jetzt dran die 500 euro frage wo
liegen bei menschen die knochen amboss
und steigbügel in den augen mit bmc im
rücken oder dem bein im film sowie
günther jauch im moment wirklich sagen
ich möchte dass ein okay ich glaub sein
frisch richtig jetzt richtig dass ihn
viele der muttertag findet
in deutschland an welchem sonntags alaa
am zweiten sonntag gar nicht im mai am
ersten sonntag oder de am vierten
sonntag
der muttertag findet dann am sonntag
statt das kann man der fragestellung
entnehmen ich gratuliere zu dieser
fähigkeit danke da geistern zu hören
kann der serie konnten da denken sie
doch erst mal bitte an ihre liebe frau
markt gibt den muttertag vergessen haben
sie mit der zufällig ein buch
geschrieben wenn ja wann kommt das
heraus
14 12 ich nehme publikumsjoker die sache
ist was wenn das publikum einfach nur
dumm leuten besteht so was mache ich
dann
dann sind ja vor allem dumm ich hatte
aber auch schon überlegt zu nehmen also
ich will jetzt auch dass neben woody 76
prozent gesagt haben dass das ist dann
wirklich dass nun ein wenn du das
projekt derzeit gefragt wie viel geld
habe ich 2000 2000 euro habe ich okay
per kran ihre 1000 euro frage wie heißt
der schnellzug in frankreich ktm ist
dass das direkt www logischer eine dich
richtig sie sind jetzt bei der 2000 euro
frage angekommen welcher begriff
entstand nach dem ausbruch des
außerirdischen im film nach hause fahren
die nach hause fliegen sie nach hause
gehen oder die nach hause telefonieren
ich dachte es kommt nach hause kommen
weil ich dachte dass der spruch ist aber
keine ahnung gibt es nie geguckt die
sache ist ich kann jetzt entweder sagen
dass ich es dabei belassen will bei den
2000 euro oder ich falle zurück auf 500
euro
ja darf ich dich war fragen was du sagen
würdest du kannst du ja auch nicht sein
ich weiß nicht aber ich denke mir halt
so die ganze zeit wenn du auch so eine
frage bekommt seit 2000 euro frage und
ich beantworte die jetzt richtig weil
ich tendiere zwischen nach hause gehen
und nach hause fahren fliegen gehen
würde ich nach hause fliegen mein gott
alter okay das wird nun eingeloggt und
korrekt wäre nach hause telefonieren
damit herkommen sind sie auf 500 euro
zurückgefallen die 2000 euro frage für
herrn kran der gehweg walk of fame
befindet sich in welcher stadt
ich war noch nie da das ist das für eine
2000 euro frage so ja klar da muss ich
an der stelle auch mal wirklich sagen
sie haben ja selber mitbekommen ich habe
ja zuerst die fragen beantwortet und bin
bei 2000 euro leider hängen geblieben
auf 58 eur zurückgefallen du bist jetzt
4000 euro möchtest du aussteigen ja ja
ich nehme mit was ich hab' creme
herzlichen glückwunsch starke 1000 euro
wir von mega geil freut mich mega an der
stelle würde ich das ganze video jetzt
auch beenden meine damen ich muss auf
die bestrafung bekommen seine fanpage
ist wieder genug material für jahre das
was ist ihr vom video meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
kenne man lag da wie gesagt kann gerne
umfrageteilnehmer mehr mobile gaming auf
meinem kanal sehen wollt uns hat auf
jeden fall eine menge spaß gemacht